hey col O'Brien here coming to you with
another clueless gamer what's happening
we are going to play
Starfield oh look at this oh there's a
ship with a grandma on it oh look at
that blow it
up yeah we can blow or we can you want
to talk to her no I want to blow up a
grandma now if there's a grandma on this
yeah she's all alone oh by herself I'm
just going to grab a quick nap well
granny guess what never travel alone
bam oh yeah oh no you're locking in on
her oh she's firing back firing back
firing back what the hell keep shooting
I am oh my God this Grandma's fired back
take that
Grandma
yes
I just love the grandmother she did
nothing to me but you know what it cost
so much to you
know elder care so
expensive maybe maybe this was a
blessing I'm the worst person alive get
us out of here you can uh go through the
wreckage on her ship and steal it okay
no it's just going to be a lot of yarn